but i'm very pleased that the
police have acted efficiently um got the
investigation completed you know the
prime minister's obviously apologized uh
for the birthday cake incident i hope
now that we can move on to really deal
with some of the big issues facing the
country like what we're talking about
today drugs uh but also you know the
cost of living crisis dealing with the
nhs backlog and showing leadership in
what is a very challenging environment
uh across the world so the investigation
is now finished
now
well it looks to me like the police
consider the mata closed
from their point of view
obviously i'm pleased that the
investigation is over i know the police
will have done their job efficiently and
well and i hope now as i say we can move
on to some of those really important
issues that the country actually wants
to focus on
well that's a matter for for others not
for me i mean obviously the police have
decided uh that it's all over um they've
handed out those fines that they want to
hand out the prime ministers apologize
for the birthday cake incident i'm sure
he and frankly the rest of the country
now want to move on to those really big
issues the war in ukraine the cost of
living crisis dealing with the drugs
problem that we've got across the
country and that i think is what we're
going to focus on from now on